[Music]
finally filming for Venom 3 has started
and the theatrical release is also as
good as set in this video we'll provide
you with all the information we know
about the project it all started with
Venom in 2018 the start of Sony's
Spider-Man universe It Was Then followed
by morbius and Venom Let There Be
Carnage but neither was really popular
with viewers nothing can be said yet
about the quality of the next two SSU
films Craven the Hunter and Madam web so
all the fans hopes rest on Venom 3 to
return to its former glory after all the
character's popularity seems to remain
undiminished the starring role in venom
3 is of course once again played by Tom
Hardy he plays the reporter Eddie Brock
who is inseparable from the alien
symbiote Venom Sony additionally
confirmed two more members of the cast
first we have British actress Juno
Temple who has been best known in recent
years for a role as key Jones in the
series Ted lasso since she was cast
early on she will surely play a leading
role the same goes for cheel EDG for
whom we already know from the doctor
strange movies where he played the role
of Baron MTO officially no other cast
members are known as of yet however
since the Symbiote Toxin has already
been teased in venom 2 we anticipate
that Steven Graham will return as
detective Mulligan he is after all the
human host of the character we're also
eager to find out whether we will
finally get to see Tom Holland in a
Venom movie there have long been rumors
that the two movie series are to be
joined and after Tom Hardy's came
appearance in Spider-Man no way home at
the latest it only seems to be a matter
of time
there are no official details about the
storyline of Venom 3 yet though there
are some hints for example the first set
pictures have already surfaced on these
we see Eddie in the same shirt and
t-shirt he wears in the mid credit scene
of no way home we recall he was pulled
into the MCU by Doctor Strange's spell
and has a bartender in Mexico tell him
about the events surrounding the
infinity Saga Venom recognizes Peter
which may be because the Symbiotes share
a common memory and another venom has
after all already encountered Toby
Maguire's Peter Parker in Spider-Man 3
after after Doctor Strange undo the
spell they are sent back to their own
Universe this could be where the plot of
Venom 3 picks up as a potential new ally
for Eddie toxin awaits toxin is the
strongest semiot we know so far he is
superior to Venom Carnage and even
Spider-Man in all respects so if he were
to play a part again the movie would
require an even stronger villain than
before we are eagerly awaiting the
official announcement of which character
it will be this
time now you're up to date on Venom 3
which V is on top of your wish list and
do you think Tom Holland and Tom Hardy
would work well together in a movie let
us know in the comments and be sure to
give the video a thumbs up we'll of
course keep you posted on further news
about Venom
[Music]